good evening counselors ladies and
gentlemen and I welcome you all here to
the meeting of the
council before we formally start the
meeting I invite the ch CH father malar
St John Henry Newman Parish to lead us
in prayer thank you
Father thank you for having me
again I've been thinking a lot what to
say today and I thought i' focus on
November November in my tradition in the
Catholic tradition to
remember it begins with two great feasts
All Saints and alls remember who we are
who we're meant to be when we remember
the
potential the
digity
that
for
thank you
Father apologies I have received
apologies for absence from councelor
Gilbert and is there any other apologies
please no right voting and broadcasting
information we have used the microphone
units in the chamber this evening for
speaking and they are worked by pressing
the bar on and
off please can all members speak closely
into the microphone to help us all hear
and to ensure that the speeches are
conveyed clearly clearly on the
broadcast may also appeal to everyone to
make sure that they're not blocking the
microphone with
papers should a vote be necessary this
evening I will ask for a show of
hands this meeting has also been
streamlined on the council committee
meeting YouTube
channel the whole of the meeting will be
recorded except where there are
confidential or exempt items and this
actively promotes Democratic engagement
in Accords with Section 100a brackets 9
of the Local Government Act
1972 thank
you before we proceed with the business
you will already have noticed that we
have another full
agenda as a reminder to all we were
required to terminate the meeting at
9:30 prompt and any agenda business that
has not been dealt with with this point
must be deferred in the event this
happens we're required to reconvene for
the council meeting urgently in order to
conclude all the
business I have already set out an email
to you all explaining the measures I
will be taking to manage the meeting
this evening in particular all agenda
items will be subject to strict timing
which means that I will be limiting the
time for speakes from the outset of the
meeting the first item is minutes and I
moved at the minutes of the meeting held
on 19th of July
2023 we taken as read and signed in
accordance with correct record is that
seconded seconded mayor all those in
favor item two is
announcements former counselor Mrs
Pamela Dixon and former mayor S Mrs
Wendy seconds it is regret that since
the last meeting former counselor Mrs
Pamela Dixon MBE and honory olderman who
was mayor of Trafford in 2004 and 2005
sadly passed
away Mrs Dixon represented Brooklyn's
Ward and served on the council for 27
years between 1990 and
2018 just these last few days we have
also been advised that the former marass
Mrs Wendy Higgins has passed away Mrs
Higgins was Maris to her husband David
in his maral year of 2009
to20 as a mark of respect to the former
colleagues I invite the council to stand
for a few moments silence in reflect of
their
memory
for
thank
you like everyone we have watched these
terrible events unfolding in Israel and
Gaza with increasing shock and horror
and our thoughts and prayers are with
those impacted and the people caught up
in the
conflict I'm going to ask everyone to
pause and take a moment to
reflect on the many innocent people that
has lost their lives or who have lost
loved ones can I ask him stun
please
thank
you his majesty the King's Birthday
honors may I take this opportunity to
recognize the citizens and persons
connected with traffic who were named in
his majesty the King's Birthday honors
list mbes were awarded to M Haley Karen
Citron from sale for serving services to
nursing Mr Jonathan Grant Evans from
hail for Service Association football in
Norther
Ireland Mrs Zoe franka Holland from s
for charitable Services particularly
during the covid-19 and Dr Rosemary
McCarthy from hail for services to VI
wiffy and maternal he
care I'm sure you will all join with me
conveying the council's congratulations
to those achievements and richly deserve
recognition thank you does the leader of
the council wish to make any brief
announcements this
evening thank you may I'm conscious this
this is uh last time we were here was
July so I do have a couple of
announcements to make and I'll be quick
um first of all I'm delighted to see
that in July uh 11 of trafford's parks
and green spaces earned the green flag
status including David Hume Park
Victoria Park and many others across the
B and I'd like to thank the friends of
parks groups as well as our officers
both in am and in Trafford Council for
all the work that they've done to uh to
get us to green flag status once again
for so many parks really pleased to see
that the council and lmq have started
work regenerating several properties in
sale more which will bring them back
into use as affordable homes again a
great example of partnership work there
in September early September thousands
welcomed the start of the tour of
Britain cycling race to Ultram it was a
really good occasion that the May was at
as well as the deputy leader and a
couple of other members as well it was a
lovely morning and really we saw s ultr
in an excellent
light Council has been awarded funding
of almost 2 million pounds to support
the building of new homes in stretford
on the Lacy Street site that was an
announcement that was made a couple of
weeks ago delighted to see that Longford
park has been awarded £3 million from
the Heritage Lottery fund as part of
their Heritage bid um again big thanks
to friends of Longford Park Ward
counselors executive members and also
our officers in the council for bringing
that together a superb Resort there for
Longford Park congratulations to rring
and bed for their successful purple flag
award I know that Council Welton and I
were on a walk um over the summer with
the assessments there and it's really
good to see altering in such a positive
light so thanks to the for that
delighted to see that hail library has
opened at long last as we can all say so
they've got a fantastic new facility in
hail and I know that residents will be
very pleased with that and I think we
were also looking forward to the next
stages on the leveling up bit the uh the
the Leisure um development that we got
in Partington some further engagement is
going to be going on from next week with
residents in Partington and finally
speaking of honors may we all convey our
congratulations to Trafford veterans
and also the special educational needs
family support group because they
recently were awarded the king's award
for voluntary service thank
you do the chairs of scrutiny committees
have anything to announce on behalf
their
committees and can you limit the
announcements to one minute
please thank thank you may um yeah I
just wanted to let everyone know in the
council chamber all the members
uh that next week we have the budget
scrutiny and it is on Tuesday the 28th
and Thursday the 30th um so you know
members are actually welcome to come to
that whether they're on this scrutiny
committee or not uh so hope they you
know hope that people will come if
they're interested in that thank you
very much May thank you
coun
coun Council B do you have anything to
report yes madame mayor thank you uh on
behalf of the health scrutiny committee
we had the task and finish group uh the
group met local prescribers and learned
how they engage with the public and how
they find uh fund themselves when
there's no local Authority
assistance we will uh we met uh uh we
will be meeting again in
December uh the the committee is halfway
through its journey and has heard from
service providers across the authority
with particular regards to altering and
minor injuries unit uh AIDS and
adaptations uh to help reduce costs and
make best use of equipment for discharge
from hospitals uh and the integrated
care board governance the committee is
hoping to learn from the integrated care
board uh about the full move and the new
government structure that's uh put in
place now and how it's affecting staff
retention as well as how it's going to
benefit the authority going forward the
next meeting this Wednesday will explore
the social care winter plans Dental
access and cancer diagnosis and
prevention as well as reviewing the
performance during the uh
pandemic thank
you councelor
West thank you chair um nothing from the
children's scrutiny um group at this at
this time thank you thank
you item three questions item three is
questions and members have submitted 12
questions for this meeting which I have
listed which has been listed on the
council website for members of the
public to view in order for effectively
managed the meeting this evening and
based on the majority support of
proposers I have determined measures
which will allow us to move through the
question
section on the agenda agenda quickly and
onto the remaining items of
business firstly on the basis that I
have asked for the responses to be
circulated to all counselors and
published on the website I will take
both the question and responses to be
read and
noted where a response is yet to be
provided we will ensure that they are
circulated after the
meeting and secondly I invite any
supplementary questions to be submitted
in right after the meeting any
supplementary questions received
together with the answers to that
questions will also be published on the
council's
website moving on now to item four
members of the
committee item four is to advise the
council about changes to the council and
appointments to meetings may I take this
opportunity to congratulate councelor
Francis Crosby on a recent election to
the council as a member of f St Martin's
Ward and welcome her to her first
meeting these changes for information
can can be noted
please thank you item five is
petitions um petitions requesting a
pedestrian Crossing on Park Ro templey
which received 615
signatures in accordance with the
council petition scheme the lead
petitioner is allowed to speak the is
allowed to speak to the petition of five
minutes and we have Helen M with us this
evening who will introduce the
petition following their introduction
the petition will be debated by Council
for a maximum of 15
minutes as it is agreed practice the
petition at council speeches are
normally limited to one member for each
group and since there's only 15 minutes
allowed for the debate each each group
will be allocated 3 minutes and 45
seconds following debate the leader of
the council will then summarize the
council's
response if the council consents to this
Arrangements I will now invite helenor
to introduce the
petition thank
you stand
Lo
l
USIS
only
Jud
Fe
too long
just
ofed
into what Cho
she so I've talked about the safs
pedestrian cross willf to Cru will
encourage people
and I
also
thank
[Applause]
you
Council adad as the executive member for
highways environment and traded Services
I invite you now to respond on behalf of
the labor
party thank you uh mayor and thank you
to Helen for presenting the petition to
council tonight where we do look at
these all very carefully and they're
actually fully assessed by our road
safety officers and need Highway's team
once your petion has been received I
don't know whether you received a for
responses yet not to it not but if if
you haven't received one yet it will be
coming in the near future following
tonight's meeting well I can say I've
been involved in a few of these
assessments so I know that they look at
it rigorously they look at the accident
record of it that they will do things
like speed assessments on the road
volumes of traffic and they will all be
considered in an
overall assessment of the road these are
these can then be put into a an area
where we can actually be assessed for
next year's budget as you will be aware
Crossings themselves in the region of
some something like 50 to 70,000 as sort
of minimum there really they some can
cost a lot more than that as well so
obviously we have to uh go through
transport for greater Manchester where
we can actually get funding for these
and and I'm aware at the moment as you
may see in the response it says there
something like in region currently seven
similar perspective projects as well
that are also requesting similar sorts
of uh Crossings now as part of that
assessment what they can look at Road
Safety officers as well they can work
with the local schools the communities
and indeed the local counselors and they
can see what other types of measures
come in if we aren't able to put in a
Crossing straight away it may well be
that we can see other measures that may
be able to help in so so we can actually
look further down the road and get some
of these Crossings in place so we do
look at these and obviously it's quite
early days in this year and I think
there a long way to go so I'd like to
thank you for presenting that to us
today and obviously and we will endeavor
to look at it and if obviously you well
come come back to us and speak to us and
let us know how this progresses we do
put in Crossings each year but as with
as with many things the cost of them are
going up hugely so we have to put them
where where it's going have the most
benefit and obviously things like
accidents and that lot of actually
Paramount in there thinking of around
those so we will get this highest
priority to look at and obiously we'll
come back to you so thank you Helen
and bye thank you council is there a
speak on behalf of the conservative
group please thank you thank you Madame
mayor um and thank you to our Resident
was it Mrs yeah thank you for thank you
for putting the petition together find
myself agreeing wholly uh with the
petitioner um there have been uh demands
for a crossing and it's sad to hear um
councel ads head say uh it's early days
uh as an ex templey counselor there've
been demands for a Crossing on Park Road
for probably getting on for a decade I
suspect if we went back to Matt College
we'd find demands for a Crossing on Park
Road for a decade um the requests to
council have been greeted with pretty
much what we we've heard tonight from
Council adsad woy words but no
commitment to a crossing and that what
you've just said there I have heard
probably half a dozen times over the
past eight years so although we've got
wly words I suspect we won't get across
it I genuinely don't think it'll make a
scrap of difference so I would appeal to
this Council for the people of templey
to give them Crossing £50,000 we've
heard we've had
five bad accidents
50,000 pounds is not a lot of money
we've just spent half a million pounds
at the top of St Margaret's road to get
a Crossing that was petitioned for three
years ago so somehow go down the back of
the Sofer find the 50,000 and do
something for Mrs or and the 5600
petitioners
please thank you
councelor I understand that councilor
Menace is to respond on behalf of the
liberal Democrat
Party thank you mayor thank you Helen
for presenting this petition the liberal
Democrats are completely supportive of
this petition I speak as a fellow
resident of simpley as a mother of
school AED children and as a nearby
resident of where this Crossing is very
much needed we've heard Helen speak
about the child who's been hit by a car
when Crossing Park Road near Stony
Bridge Lane I know that the routs that
the children who attend Wellington
School take when they live on the North
side of Park Road or off it many walk
along Stony Bridge Lane across the park
and along bucking and way as the cut
through to Grove Lane I take the same
route with my youngest to the Willows
Primary School my eldest travels the
same route himself to Wellington School
we live on the south side and I fear my
eldest Crossing Park Road to visit
friends who live on the other side
children cross the road to meet their
friends on the other side of the
road directly outside my house which is
the corner of lindgate drive on Park
Road there is a bus stop that is
predominantly used by school children
going to other
schools and by elderly residents my
elderly residents many of whom cross par
to get to that bus stop outside my house
elderly residents have told me firsthand
how they would love nothing more than to
have this Crossing because they get that
bus most days it's their way of getting
places because they can't drive anymore
and they have enthusiastically signed
this petition not a single resident
opposes it I've spoken to them all those
of us who live nearby know how much it's
needed we see the near misses
the second timle Scout Hut is on Hayes
Drive which the scouts walk to and it's
also used for other community groups The
Crossing would be well
used once it is there more would use it
as active transport rather than getting
in their cars year six children at the
Willows primary are a perfect example
thus reducing the parents driving to
school and the traffic traffic problems
that the parking then creates near the
school and all the safety Parts with
that
given the times a day that it's going to
be used which is going to be all day
because it's not just around school
times and the location of being near the
Haz Lane Junction a pelican Crossing
would be the best option to avoid
needing a lollipop person which are in
short supply and generally require a
school nearby to get one the zebra
Crossing by Westwood Avenue is quite far
away and requires a lollipop person at
school times due to the failure of cars
to stop I've used start Crossing loads
of times where whereas The Crossing near
the timley tram stop doesn't as the
drivers tend to stop at red lights I
urge everybody and I urge the council to
find the funding to pay for this tra
this Crossing because otherwise we're
going to land up how how much is it
going to take one child's been hit could
be a lot worse couldn't it what the
injuries suffered could be a hell of a
lot worse and what are you going to be
waiting for thank you very much thank
you
counselor and could I have a speaker for
the green party please
thanks chair uh Trafford green party
fully support this
petition sorry Park Road is notoriously
dangerous from timley Village to MOS
Lane a one mile stretch there a no road
safety features at all at all and this
petition States Stony Bridge Lane is a
desire line for many children on their
way to school our kids once 11 are often
left to navigate dangerous vs like this
on a near daily basis
I live a Stones Throw from this stretch
of road I remember the day when my
daughter Ash and face ran screaming
towards our house telling us that her
friend had been hit by a car I saw the
faces of stricken parents standing
nearby fortunately on this occasion no
lasting physical damage was done but it
could have been very different I'm sure
the me mental scars still remain and
parents will continue to live live in
fear day after day we need to take road
safety seriously that's why the green
party recently passed a vision zero
Motion in this chamber it s it sets a
plan to reduce Road fatalities and
serious injuries to zero in a 15-year
time scale it also delivers the measures
for doing it in Park Road we can start
to look at Road designs lad Safety
Solutions to make the road safer we can
reduce the speed limit of vehicles to 20
mil hour we can rebalance our roads
towards segregated walking and cycling
routes as well these things things can
be achieved with political will of
course it is harder when this Tory
government cuts the active travel
funding by two3 this year alone however
we urge this Council to undertake a
safety ordit of this stretch of Park
Road just as we did in gry Lane Crossing
four years ago Spades are now in the
ground
there
sorry so we we need to make these
changes we need to on the V Vision zero
ideas and we need to make this stretch
of road safe for all of us thanks chair
thank you finally the leader of the
council summarizes what will now happen
with the petition
please thank you very much may and thank
you Helen for clearly presenting a
powerful argument there um members may
know this but I actually grew up very
close to where the proposed site for the
uh the Pelican CR Crossing is I lived
over the bridge just before timley
Village in the in in in houses there so
I know the area very very well I grew up
there very familiar with the streets
from the age I could walk upwards so I
know how busy and dangerous Park Road is
I'm also really pleased to hear the
appetite from local residents that
signed that petition and signed it in
Great numbers so very quickly the
appetite there is for shared Road space
for active travel to make for making
things safer for pedestrians for
cyclists sharing balance a bit like um
what has just been said um by by the
green party I think that's really
encouraging and I'd like to say from
when I became leader at the start of
this year one of the priorities that I
have had is progressing active travel we
have had significant investment me and
our executive member for climate change
we been working very closely with Dame
SAS story uh Chris borman's successor to
um to ensure that we get more active
travel routes on the ground as quickly
as possible that takes working with Ward
counselors that takes working with uh
working with local residents more
importantly and so there is the
political will to do that and to support
schemes where we can and I'm very happy
to speak to council Williams speak to
councelor ad said look at what we can do
to Lia with transport for greater
Manchester and Ward counselors to see if
there's some progress that we can make
with this particular request
unfortunately and I know you'll know
this already there isn't a sofa that we
can just get our hand down to get 50
Grand on back of I think Council Evans
knows that as well but what we can do is
look into what we can do with with with
officers with residents to see how we
can progress this because as I say it's
an area I know very very well and you
put forward a very clear case as to why
we need to look at better road safety
measures so thank you and we'll work
together and see what we can respond
with thank you counselor thank you
leader item six is the street trading
policy which has been referred from the
executive and and time for speeches will
be limited the proposal will be afforded
2 minutes and all other speeches will be
limited to 1 minute each I invite
executive member of communities and
safety to introduce the report and move
the
recommendations councelor Thompson
please thank you I presented to the
executive meeting on the 18th of October
and you're welcome to view this on our
YouTube channel so I don't propose to
give a full presentation tonight the
sake of brevity and the packed agenda
and having only a minute or two so a
very quick summary of the policy is that
earlier this year we reviewed our
decision-making processes and fees
charged to produce an upto-date cohesive
policy this policy introduces two new
zoned areas Zone a around Manchester
United and lanasia CET ground and uh and
zones B and C around sale and altering
them this is where a consent will be
needed I'm happy to report that this
simplification of the licensing rules
will result in a reduction of 50% of the
fees in zone a and a tiny increase in
other
areas I want to reassure Charities and
the volunteering Community sector and
Community benefit groups that they will
not be required to pay the fees and the
policy does not have any effect impact
on our street fairs and
markets if approved this will come into
effect on the 1 of December and I want
to thank the licensing team for their
great work on this policy thank you
thank you councelor he that seconded
please seconded mayor thank you there's
any members wishes to speak on this
report
please Council of Bo just a moment okay
go ahead Council
thank you Madame mayor uh the vast
majority of councils of Greater
Manchester uh charge under 1,000 for
Street trading
fees how can Trafford Council charge a
whopping
1,679 to be exact when compared to
Manchester which charges
£720 Manchester also has significantly
large
venues how can shadford Council justify
such a high ancillary cost as they call
it when compared with
Manchester also justifies it by saying
just it's to support and Safeguard the
sustainability and Street trading and
inid and procedures are consistent and
appropriate and fairly in line with best
practice nationally so small uh small
Street Traders do not have the comfort
of secure jobs pensions or unions in
most cases so why is it council is bent
on making their livelihood un viable
thank
you thank thank you counselor the report
has been moved and seconded can it be
agreed
please thank
you item seven is another licensing
policy referred to from the executive
regarding hack carriages and private
hire again the proposal will be afforded
two minutes and all other speeches will
be limited to one minute I invite the
executive member for communities and
safety to introduce the report and move
the recommendations
councelor
Thompson again I presented this policy
to Executive last week so I will just
summarize some of the important
headlines the overarching purpose of the
policy is to um improve the safety of
our vulnerable PE our vulnerable adults
and children and support the CLE
Manchester clean air plan in preparing
the policy we've brought in the greater
Manchester the minimum licensing
standards but bringing in some
amendments following on from the
consultation we did with our taxi
drivers and
operators in recognition of the
financial burden on drivers in replacing
their vehicles the restrictions of vles
being under 5 years old for private hire
and under seven years old for haty
carriages has been removed however
however they will still have to conform
to the emission
standards there are ongoing discussions
between the transport for greater
Manchester and the government and all 10
authorities have been asked to agree in
a mission standard with the possibility
of starting this sooner than
2026 therefore it is proposed that the
director of place and the exact member
be delegated the power to do this if
deemed
appropriate um and I want to thank all
the offices in licensing team for
producing this uh wide ranging and up
toate polic say thank
you thank you thank you counselor is
that second
please um it is seconded thank you mayor
and I'll respectfully request that I
remain seated just to um second this
report if that's okay for eyesight
reasons um so I'll just very briefly
reiterate um my support that I um voiced
in the exec meeting um and this is on
the ground really that as a disabled
person who can't drive or use public
transport I do use a lot of of taxes um
and I know that many disabled vulnerable
um older people and children rely on
taxes to travel um and as such I think
it is really important that the
licensing standards um Safeguard and
protect passengers um and I'm pleased
that these proposals will do that um in
great Manchester thank you
mayor thank you
counselor does any members wishes to
speak on this report please councilor
Evans thank you Madame mayor um I'd like
to well we will be supporting the report
um and I'd like to thank the uh
executive member for the removal of the
age restrictions um taxi operators are
strugling that that would be an
understatement most are not barely
viable um and hearing what the deputy
leader said it's a crucial service but
if we push them too far so I think the
move the move it and the uh revisions
are very helpful thank you thank you
councelor the report has been moved and
seconded can it be agreed
please thank
you item eight concerns the Civic
allowances review for the
morality The Proposal will be afforded
two minutes and all other speeches will
be limited to one minute I now invite
councelor Harding executive member for
finance change and governance to
introduce the report please councilor
Harden thank you mayor the report tabled
at Agenda item eight sets out the
findings and recommendations of review
by the chair of the independent
remuneration panel into the Civic
allowances for the mayor and deputy
mayor of
Trafford the council is asked to
consider the recommendations are set out
on page two of appendix one
Civic allowances are paid to the mayor
and Deputy Mayor and these allowances
fall outside the remake of the 2003
members allowances regulation and are
not considered as part of the
independent remuneration panel into
members
allowances section one of the report
sets out the background section two the
terms of reference and section three the
recommendations it is recommended that
the Civic allowance for the mayor of
Trafford council is reset £110,000 per
year and that the deputy mayor allowance
is reset to 2,500 per year it is also
recommended that recommendations
outlined in the report are updated from
the date of the annual general meeting
2023 it is noted it's been at least 10
years since they were last reviewed and
the report outlines the current
situation and a benchmarking exercise
with other greater Manchester
authorities which is included in the
report it is further noted that Civic
allowances of £10,000 for the traffic
Council May would still leave it as the
lowest Civic allowance across the 10
greater Manchester councils I refer
Council to section 25 to outline the
rationale for the recommendations and
move the report for um acceptance of the
recommendations I think we all value the
role of the mayor and Deputy Mayor as to
the value they bring to Trafford meeting
our Charities residents and um spreading
the good name of Trafford across this
bough thank you mayor
thank you counselor is that seconded
please um yes it is seconded thank you
mayor um and I'm really pleased to
Second the report um as has been
outlined as an authority we will Begin
to Fall quite some way behind the other
GM authorities in how we remunerate the
mayor um and it's absolutely right that
we reset the allowances as proposed in
the report the mayor is the first
citizen of the bough and um and the
mayor undertakes such an important role
um there an ambassador for Trafford and
are also the way that so many of our
residents children and young people
Charities and organizations connect with
the council um the mayor undertakes a
huge amount of important work on our
behalf and I'm happy to support the
proposals thank you thank you councelor
does any members wish to speak on the
report
please Council Goggins counc edans counc
Goin
please um thank you mayor uh the green
group uh will support the
recommendations of the independent panel
and the continuing to have the lowest
rates in graer Manchester for this and
we also really appreciate the work that
both the current H mayor and Deputy
Mayor and and recent uh Mayors and
Deputy Mayors have done um I did want to
draw attention however to the fact as
well as the mayor's allowance the report
does mention the mayor's fund which is a
further £10,000 which does include the
costs of the mayor's car um and we do
want to raise again as we have done
before that actually in a climate crisis
it isn't clear that taxpayers funds are
well spent on taxing uring repairing and
fueling and buying or leasing a maral
car especially a luxurious one and
especially in a small burrow like
Trafford which has good active and
public transport transport
options I said which okay it could be
better we could have much better active
transport okay but also
also um there could be SC scope for
reducing the cost the report also
mentions the dinner for counselors which
includes other guests as well and of
course um alcohol costs are are are
mentioned in there as well and again it
is a question I think in a cost of
living crisis it really isn't obvious
that all of these are essential uses of
residence funds so the green group
really want to say that while we really
value the contributions people are
making we do think that given our coun
and financial questions we could do it
some answers thank
you right the report has been oh
councilor Evan
sorry thank you madam thank you Madame
mayor
um um it's a it's a shame the executive
member has conflated uh the value of the
meraly with the value of the re
renumeration I want to make it really
clear this conservative group values the
mayor specifically role you're uh
completing today um but we can't we
didn't support the 40% uh allowance
increase for those members uh and
unfortunately we won't be supporting
this thank
you the report has been moved and
seconded can it be
agreed
um item nine is motions this evening
seven motions has been listed on the
summonses in order that they were
received proposal will be given two
minutes and all other speeches will be
limited to one minute please therefore
can we keep our speeches concise and try
to invite petitions repetitions of
points already made by other members and
hopefully this will give everybody who
wants to an opportunity to
speak it may be necessary to further
limit the time for speeches to enable us
to get through the business in
time we're moving on to motion
9A proceeding then with the first motion
regarding the climate and ecology bill
which you will now recall was deferred
from our July
meeting I have received notice that
councelor Welton is to move it please
councilor Welton thank you mayor we
first proposed this Motion in July
hoping to align Trafford with the 250
councils that already support the
climate and ecology Bill and to pay
tribute to one of the Bill's major
supporters Caroline Lucas as her time as
parliamentary standard Bearer for the
environment draws to a close we felt at
the time that it might be
uncontroversial that there was still a
broad consensus in our Council and
country that we had to step up to tackle
the twin threats of climate emergency
and biodiversity crisis since then the
warnings about the harm mankind is doing
to climate and nature have only grown
more urgent both from the scientists and
mother nature herself we've seen climate
fuel disaster after disaster from the
vast Canadian fires to the death of
20,000 people in Libya following storm
danials excess rainfall sea surface
temperatures have hit record highs for
four straight months Antarctic sea ice
collapsed to a historic glow
concentrations of carbon dioxide hit 421
parts per million the last time they
were that high was 4 million years ago
when oceans were over 20 M higher than
today CO2 emissions reached a new high
of 39 gigatons per year at a time when
they already need to be declining
rapidly to keep within the target of 1.5
degrees warming the number of species at
risk of Extinction has doubled to 2
million according to the to the UN and
only 14% of our nation's rivers are
currently achieving good ecological
status so what is our PR prime
minister's response to the red flashing
lights on our planetary dashboard just
since July he's committed to pumping out
more oil and gas from the North Sea and
opening a Coal Mine He's pushed back
targets for replacing gas guzzling cars
and boilers with clean tech his
government has mismanaged the sale of
offshore wind license to wind licenses
to the point that there were no takers
to expand production of our cheapest and
cleanest source of electricity he's
changed the law to make it easier to
lock up climate protest while appointing
just last week an environment Minister
who Pockets money from a major donor to
a climate skeptic Think Tank and just
this week can you wrap up please I can
indeed and just this week the high court
has ruled that his government has failed
in their duty to protect our waterways
from
pollution that is why it is important to
to support this Bill thank you very much
thank you
councelor uh Council Lester is a second
motion
please thank you chair
um I'd like to ask members to think back
to when they were younger do you
remember when you couldn't leave a jam
jar outside because you'd be mobbed by
wasps if you left your door open in the
summer any food you left out would be
covered with flies and flies would be
buzzing around the light bulbs if you
let the left the window open at night
you'd have daddy long legs flitting
around the room if you went on Holiday
by car you could barely see through the
wind screen due to splattered insects
you couldn't cycle without getting
insects into your mouth and eyes at the
time those things were seen as a
nuisance but now they become a thing of
the past and this is a real worry with
global temperatures warming insects and
birds are becoming active earlier and
beginning to lose synchronization with
the plants that they rely on for food
and in turn we l lose the wildlife that
we don't rely on for pollination for our
food as each new generation inherits the
world vital knowledge is forgotten as
the new generations don't know a world
when we had rivers and seas full of fish
and an environment full of insects and
birds and other animals this is
dangerous because people people don't
see the changes only recently we saw saw
the impact of global warming here
locally with the death of all the local
fish thank you C thank you please
support this
motion the motion has been moved in
second do any members wish to speak
please councilor
Roy councelor broy can we
have thank
you we have
um one
minute sorry two minutes did you say one
minute
okay there's no issue more important
than protecting our climate without a
healthy Planet there's no sustainable
future for humankind so zero hour is the
name of the campaign supporting the
climate and emergency bill the bill
ensures that the UK should do everything
it can to keep global warming to 1.5
degrees and reverse biodiversity by loss
by
2030 so online searches reveal climate
anxiety have increased dramatically in
recent years particularly amongst young
women and people young people perhaps I
was ahead of my time but I think I've
experienced climate anxiety most of my
adult life so I wrote something in 2002
that said the latest data on global
warming suggests we will reach the point
of no return within the next 5 to 10
years and I'm very sad that in my
lifetime we have reached the point of
turn the damage to our planet is
irreversible because politicians back
then didn't listen to what the
scientists were saying the current Tory
government under sunac are still not
listening causing despair to the science
Community despair to those who thank you
coun please support this motion I'm
sorry we haven't got more time to to
give it the importance that it deserves
thank you thank you councilor xford
please
um I'm speaking in support of this
motion as in the words of Kevin Anderson
the highly renowned energy and climate
change profess at the Tindle Center it
provides a real framework for developing
meaningful climate and nature
legislation as it's the only proposed
plan for legislation that calls for a
whole government approach to address the
interconnections between climate
environmental degradation and
biodiversity loss this bill is unique in
that it not only addresses both the
climate and biodiversity crisis but also
the need to transition to fairer and
more sustainable society and calls to
set up a representative climate and
nature assembly to ensure true public
involvement the first version of this
bill was introduced to Parliament in
2020 as a cross party initiative by
Karen and Lucas with the support and
committed hard work of Labor EMP Clive
Lewis it was reintroduced to Parliament
by lab MP Olivia Blake in 2023 it's
currently supported on the latest
figures by about 300 councils 132 cross
party employes including 65 labor MPS
and for conservatives and also by Sadi
KH the CE Bill exemplifies the cross
party approach is absolutely essential
coun to tackle the climate crisis I'd
urge you all to support it thank you so
much councelor Williams
please thank you chair given the be busy
agenda this evening I intend to keep my
comments brief I welcome this motion and
the Parliamentary Bill and I'm pleased
that it is enjoyed cross Party Support
as at Westminster as councelor Axford
was indicating meaningful progress on
carbon reduction and environmental
Improvement is most most likely to be
secured through robust action by central
government it is absolutely about time
that greater focus and resourcing is
given to the climate crisis by our
country's leaders and it is therefore
crucial that pressure is kept on our
parliamentarians this is particularly
important given the prime minister's
recent attempts to shove the climate
crisis down the political agenda and to
turn environmental Improvement into the
latest culture war in a desate desperate
effort to Garner political support
hopefully members of traffic Council can
rise above such sentiment and send a
clear message by supporting the motion
before this this evening thank you chair
thank you counselor councelor Welton you
have one minute to reply please should
you wish to do so counc Evans yeah go
ahead councelor
Evans thank thank you Madame may I won't
waste too much of your time um the
second uh of this motion you come to my
Terrace next spring certainly not suffer
with that was problem um however this
motion I think we forget where we are is
well above our pay grade um our group
won't be supporting it our group won't
overly be engaging with it green seem to
forget we are local counselors
representing local people on local
issues best thing they could have done
would have supported the anti-b building
on Carrington Moss the anti-b building
on the timly wedge which they duly
didn't that would have given us some
space between us in the airport would
have saved a carbon sink over in
Carrington so you seek to flatter
yourselves that you're on some sort of
national stage you're not we are local
counselors we should be talking about
local issues thank
you councelor Ross thank you ma' I'm
sorry that was a ridiculous contribution
there everything is
local speaking as the uh the Green City
region portfolio holder I have to say
there are so many exciting things
happening not just in traffic but across
cross greater Manchester that people
that are driven by communities that we
all represent there is such a big
interlocking between local and
addressing the climate crisis that you
can't get away with saying that it's got
nothing to do with that and it us and it
below our pay grade we all have a part
to play in addressing the climate crisis
we've all seen the the way that drains
and have been overwhelmed with water The
Heavy Rain that's coming down it's
having a direct impact on our costs as a
council so we all have to do something
about it so I couldn't let that go thank
thank you may thank you
counselor right um okay everybody else
finished uh councelor Welton you have
one minute to reply please thank you
thank you very much and it seems like
it's not only rishy sunak that doesn't
get it in the conservative party in
trffic we need to be cutting emissions
by 177% a year to meet our own targets
we have four years left in our carbon
budget otherwise we're using more than
our fair share but let's think about
what we can do for a start let's think
the policies that will actually make it
harder or even impossible to meet our
own targets and it's these are hard
choices but PL plans to build a major
new road across Carrington Moss plans to
double the use of Manchester Airport
over the next 20 years using 1 billion
pounds of taxpayers money to prop up
fossil fuel Giants by the greater
Manchester pension fund you know wise
words are are important and I really
appreciate the support of people in this
room but we really really need to think
about the major DEC decisions that are
going to help make our Target bring us
Clos to our Target and certainly not
push us further away from them thank you
very much for everyone who supported
this thank you councelor I will now put
the motion to the vote and can I have a
short hands please and keep your hands
raised while a record is taken please
thank
you thank
you Al was against
please any AB
abstainers the motion is
carried the next motion this evening is
about weed spraying program and is to be
moved by councelor FR
please thank you mayor I submitted this
motion back in September but of course
October fold Council couldn't go ahead
residents feel that uh these weeds are a
permanent reminder that the country is
quite literally going to seed that's why
so many people wanted me to put it on
the agenda but after our motion was
submitted the Administration has since
taken on the issue and a similar plan I
think splitting the teams rather than
alternating them is now already lined up
for 2024 councelor adad tells me so
therefore since we now have these plans
underway and in the interest of time for
other motions so that we're not cut
short I am withdrawing this motion with
the consent of the seconder thank
you thank you uh councilor renis do you
want to second the motion the motion has
been withdrawn okay right thank
you
right
right on motion 9C the the next motion
this evening is about business rides
retention and is to be moved by
councilor Enis
please businesses in Trafford face
enormous challenges brexit has made it
harder for our local businesses to
thrive and has led to supply chain
issues across all Industries the
covid-19 pandemic exacerbated these
pressures and forced huge changes to the
way we work shop and travel as if all
that wasn't enough the trust
Administration has been an unmitigated
disaster which hammered the economy and
set back the recovery of businesses in
Trafford throughout this period of
turbulence and volatility it's been the
small businesses on which so many of our
residents rely which have borne the most
severe consequences liberal Democrats
have spoken to our local businesses and
there is an overwhelming sense of
insecurity and anxiety out there now
local government Finance is in crisis
too numbers of councils across the
country are facing strain caused by
underfunding and compounded by runaway
inflation and a conservative government
in Westminster that doesn't care many
councils are facing the daunting
Prospect of issuing a section 114 notice
as one of the worst funded councils in
the country Trafford is extremely
vulnerable to these current pressures
we've already heard from councilor
Hardin last week that Trafford may need
to draw down its Reserves at an alarming
rate in the future to present a balanced
budget which brings me to the aims of
this motion Andy Burnham's Trailblazer
Devolution deal is far from perfect but
it does deliver certainty over the
business rate's growth retention scheme
for a further 10 years and this presents
us with an opportunity to get a fairer
deal for Trafford because right now the
fact is Trafford is leaving money on the
table for the combined Authority money
that could be better put to better use
here in Trafford if we retain more of
our growth Revenue we could offset the
need to draw down those reserves and we
could fund initiatives that support our
high streets for the long term
initiatives like free parking schemes
because free parking is not just for
Christmas councilor
Evans the B the benefits of business
rates growth should be felt by the
businesses themselves retaining more
growth would give this Council Greater
ability to support the business
community and in turn drive further
growth rat retention was renegotiated
before during the pandemic when there
was agreement that councils needed
emergency support we should do that
again thank you coun madam May thank you
is the motion seconded
please thank you mayor I'll be seconding
this councilor Enis has just outlined
why we feel this is important I wanted
to talk very briefly not just about the
need for us to retain our business rates
but actually why we should have a fairer
way to decide how much we hand over to
the combined Authority basically flat
rates attacks are not very Progressive
and neither is a flat rate for our
contributions to the gmca each burrow is
in a different different financial
position Manchester City Council sits on
relatively large reserves in comparison
to Trafford but they hand over 25% of
that business rate's growth to the
combined Authority but Trafford with far
lower reserves could be forced to spend
a significant chunk of our reserves to
balance the books next year so when we
have to hand over 25% of our business
rate grows to Andy Burnham's office it
hurts it hurts us more than our
neighbors the last time that we voted to
influence great Manchester policy that
was on Late Night trams uh I said
leveling up was going to be nothing more
than a slogan we took on the challenge
and made it happen since then we
promised uh some trams that we had nine
years ago the point is I don't hold out
much hope that the government is going
to step in and help us so we can grab
the reins ourselves and go some way to
uh addressing the unfair funding thank
you
sorry the motion has been moved and
seconded there's any members wish to
speak please counc
Harding Willam uh thank you mayor um I
don't propose to go through the
complexities of business rates in a
minute because I don't think I stand a
chance of doing that the labor party
won't be supporting this motion but
there is a lot that I empathize with the
words that you you reference there is a
memorandum of understanding between
greater Manchester and dook and that
talks about how the share will be split
and I'm very happy to meet with you
councelor Andis outside of this meeting
to to discuss that we need to keep
challenging gmca we absolutely do to
make sure how the money is being spent
you conflate parking charges as well and
there's a little bit about the
introduction of parking charges as a
false economy I just want to refer to
councilor abin because I'm really
disappointed that you bring local
government Finance down to the back of a
sofa because the Autumn statement there
are no crumbs in that Autumn statement
for local government you sat in that
exact meeting the draft budget you see
the reality of what this looks like for
us in local government so I don't want
to be flippant about the back of a sofa
because there isn't a back of a sofa
here in Trafford so whilst it is a false
economy sorry thank you m I will meet
you outside of this meeting councelor
Anice if you want to discuss further the
business rates issue thank you councelor
s
please uh thank you mayor uh we in the
green party are very clear that we'd
support transformative changes to
taxation Ally fairer redistribution of
wealth and better support for local
economies we're also clear that yes
Trafford is atrociously underfunded but
every single local Authority is also
underfunded and this motion is a Time
Warp 10 years back when Eric pickle with
Eric pickles championing councils
raiding their reserves to plug gaps gaps
created by the choice of austerity
economics made by conservatives and
Liber together rewarding councils for
failing to sustain appropriate reserves
is entirely wrong as for what
constitutes appropriate reserves the
last four years surely have shown how
important it is for local government to
be prepared for truly catastrophic
events then we have this non-sequitor
about free vehicle parking in templey um
let's be honest this motion is really
just about generating a headline for the
next local leaflet and we will not not
be supporting it thank you councelor
Williams
please thank you chair Trafford is part
of a family of local authorities in
Greater Manchester um the liberal
Democrat group are correct that like
sford in Manchester we do enjoy greater
business rate Revenue but unlike rdale
and oldum which was not mentioned by the
liberal Democrat group we do not perhaps
struggle with this with such high levels
of deprivation that is the whole point
of the current Arrangement and I support
the sentiment of solidarity that sits
behind it simply C it seems to me that
this motion if it was implemented would
would result in a selfish outcome
despite that I am sure that is not your
intention in moving it so I will not be
supporting the motion before us this
evening thank you chair thank you
counselor councelor Enis you have one
minute reply should you wish to thank
you mayor and I welcome the debate that
we've had tonight there is no conflation
um with parking charges um councelor
Harding we're talking about the tangible
benefits that a renegotiation could
bring for our residents and we're
signaling where we would uh where we
would take that um councelor Williams in
my own Ward there are pockets of
deprivation so I challenge you on that
of course yeah I I take that point and
we're thinking about that deprivation
when we move this motion so it's clear
that from the debate which way going to
head but there is no conflation
whatsoever and liberal Democrats are
very very pleased to have brought this
motion to the
chamber thank you
councelor I will now put the motion to
the vote please and can I show have a
show of hands and keep your hands raised
while a record is taken please thank
you all those in favor sorry yeah
sorry thank you
all those
against thank
you any
extensions thank
you the motion is lost thank
you the next motion concerns vaping and
invite Council Slater to move the motion
please um thank you mayor and um thank
you thank you to um the liberal
Democrats and the green party for your
amendments and we will be accepting them
amendments because they strengthen this
motion so thank you um I think we all
recognize that vaping is becoming um
quite a big issue for our young people
across across um Trafford and also
across the country and vaping is Rec is
a recognized Aid to giving up smoking
for adults and we should continue to
encourage adults to give up nicotine by
using VAP vaping as an alternative to
stop smoking
however we see that vaping is now
deliberately targeted at our young
people that that there are so many high
streets now across Trafford that have
two or perhaps even three vaping shops
the government need to look at this um
urgently and change the legislation
around this trend we see brightly
colored packaging and an array of
flavors it is deliberate it's a
deliberate marketing tool to attract to
the young um inter vaping um the same
way smoking was in the past what we need
to see now is plain packaging and uh
Vape being sold behind lots of Cupboards
in the same way that smoking is um we
asked our young people in a recent
survey around um vaping and most of them
said that it's something that they had
considered but they would never have
considered smoking so we do need to do a
lot of Education around smoking because
it is sorry around vaping because it is
um taking in nicotine in a similar in a
similar way it has long-term impacts on
our young people um Lots most of you
will be aware of um a condition that's
called um popcorn lung and this is uh
has real lifelong uh long lifelong
impacts on our young people uh popcorn
lung is caused by um a chemical in The
Vape it's called di dite and it causes
broncular obstructions which is actually
SC scarring of our young people's
Airways and Loans this chemical was
actually used um in the microwave
popcorn industry and that's where it
gets its name from it was it was used to
make uh popcorn taste buttery and um
taste and taste Cal I can't even say it
so you know it actually um causes sorry
it causes just let me say this one bit I
think we need to be mindful that
actually hundreds of people have died
from popcorn lung in the microwave uh
popcorn industry so we just need to keep
our children safe in Trafford so please
support the motion thank you thank you
mayor thank you by a second motion
please thank you mayor I would like to
Second this motion because I strongly
believe that we have a collective duty
to protect our youth from the harmful
effect of waping or commonly known as um
use of ecigarette the use in the rise in
the use of the waping devices amongst
our youth is very alarming the NHS
website States and I quote waping is not
completely harmless and we only
recommended for adult smokers to support
quitting smoking and staying quit it
further States clearly non-smokers and
young people under 18 should not be
raping the Center for Disease Control
and prevention states that young people
who are using ecigarette I.E waping may
be more likely to smoke cigarettes in
the
future it is noted that most wpes
contain nicotine which is the addictive
drug in regular cigarette cigars and
other tobacco products some W products
labels do not disclose that they contain
nicotine and some W liquids marketed as
containing 0% nicotine have also been
found to have nicotine nicotine can harm
the developing youth brain as the brain
keeps developing until the age of 25
using nicotine in youth can harm the
parts of the brain that controls
attention learning mood and impulse
control
weaping can also lead to antisocial
behavior and this can further result in
criminal engagement I therefore fully
support this Motion in its current form
thank you thank
you I have received notice of two
amendments to this motion I invite
councilor Spencer to move the First
Amendment you have two
minutes sorry I think we've uh agreed to
withdraw our Amendment and to Second the
liberal Democrat Amendment thank you
that's okay thank you the first
amendment has been moved and I move on
to the second amendment I now invite
Council FR to move the Second
Amendment you thank you may thank you
and thank you to the green group for
agreeing to combine our two amendments
tonight to save some further time this
evening making it a joint libdem green
Amendment the cynical tactics used by
the more dubious manufacturers and
retailers to deliberately appeal to
children to start using a nicotine
product is a very useful reminder of why
regulation is on the whole a good thing
those who seek quick political
advantages by promising to cut red tap
would do well to remember that now
actually I was reassured to see this
motion because I think well some time
ago a few months ago in a committee
councelor Ross talked about his desire
to tackle underage smoking and vaping
clearly that's not been forgotten so
it's really good to see that thank you
each of us is asked to Lobby our MPS to
support the aims of this motion
of course lived mmps have done that
already there was a lot in the press
back in the Autumn conference season but
we're all walking down the street or
we're all at the tram stop and you get
the smell of someone vaping emanating
from people far too young to smoke or
even on the tram engulfed in a miasma of
cherry flavored Vapes or something so
only to get off the tram and find dozens
of the brightly colored things littering
the platform and the Pavements why
because they're throwaway items they're
single use if you're a teenager who
doesn't want m dad to catch you at one
of these things you're far more likely
to buy a single use one so finally I
just want to add the single-use ones are
often poorly made and they're
contaminated with heavy metals like
chromium lead cadmium toxic to health
and damaging to landfill when they leak
out in the environment and millions of
these things are thrown out every week
so this is why the Liv Dem policy goes a
bit further in order to tackle single
use Vapes that's part of the strategy to
deal with underage vaping thank
you thank you uh Council Spencer is to
Second the amendment
please thank you I'm sure we're all
aware of how much of an issue disposable
Vapes cause in terms of litter as has
just been mentioned disposable Vapes are
completely unnecessary and a waste of
valuable resources when reusable ones
exist and are readily available it
shouldn't be the responsibility of the
council or Community litter piing group
litter picking groups to have to remove
these from our streets research shows
that sing will use Vapes are the most
common form chosen by children and young
people the lithium batteries are highly
flammable and when they're not disposed
of properly they leech harmful chemicals
into the environment and so we'd ask
everyone here to support this and to
write to the government to urge them to
ban the sale of single use Vapes the
industry needs an overhaul and to be
managed properly with effective
regulation thank you thank
you does any members wish to speak on
this please
councelor
go ahead
Council thank you mayor just briefly and
it's a on on a slight issue that hasn't
been uh part of the debate so far
obviously whilst I support all elements
that have been raised for all reasons
outline what I do want to talk about is
particular these disposable rates uh I
actually sit on the uh V Manchester
waste committee and we regularly receed
reports about these single disposable
Vapes actually causing fires as in part
of the uh the centers where all our
waste goes and they having to put in
very very expensive fire suppression
measures and and and the problem comes
that if some of them were to fail to
work although they're insured it could
take out one of these centers for 18
months and you can imagine the sort of
chaos that would actually cause I think
this at least one of our own bin loves
has actually had a fire which is a
triple to something like this so I think
it's an area of real concern that we
share in that sense so I think the
particularly disposable Vapes really are
really harm not just harmful but I think
they're causing these fires some of you
may have seen a program on this uh I
think it late last last week just
following breakfast news about 9:00 in
the morning there's a program on BBC
there and it and from the great
Manchester waste and they actually went
into the detail this so it's it's an
area of real concern so I'm really
pleased to actually support this motion
tonight and thank you
all thank you could I have councelor
shankin please thank you thank you thank
you may happy to support this amendment
and also the motion uh single use
disposal wpes are plastic kids they are
they are the entry level for our
children I support Banning diso uh
disposable could help us stopping single
use Plastics as well as well as protect
our children and young people thank
you thank you do we have any other
speakers yeah Council go
ahead you
sorry thank you um it really feels like
we're well behind uh the curve here in
terms of of the public health issue that
we're facing with vaping only last week
a concerned resident in in salmore got
in touch with me about a brand new
display in in one of our largest
convenience stores in the middle of the
village I went and had a look it's
bright it's uh attractive it's designed
to look like Fizzy Pop it's not um
behind the counter it's immediately in
front of it and it's leveled at child's
eye level dozens and dozens of products
black current squash pink lemonade all
perfectly legal but it really feels like
it flies in the face of of the
restrictions that we fought Public
Health uh gains we've made around
tobacco and alcohol around particularly
targeting children that this that this
is happening in a national chain of
convenience stores is really deeply
worrying about how embedded this the
sale of VES has become thank
you thank you counc forel um yeah
councilor Paul please
uh thank you chair um I would like to
support the amendment and the motion uh
in the child uh in the children and
young people scrutiny committee
yesterday we came across alarming
statistics of underage weaping and traid
so it is great to see our Council
attempting to take measures to mitigate
the usage of Vape by young children
thank
you thank
you I will now move directly to vote on
the amendment and then without further
debate vote on the
motion Council Slater you have one
minute and write reply should you wish
to thank you mayor I'd just like to
thank everybody for supporting the
motion and I just think it's really
important that actually we wouldn't have
litter from Vapes if we can educate our
children and get the funding from for
public health and to do to do what they
need to do so thank you for um
supporting everybody and let's hope that
we can see a change in Trafford
thank you counselor I'll now put the
amendment to the vote and can I have a
show of hands please and keep your hands
raised while the record has been taken
thank
you all those in
favor all those
against any
extensions the amendment is
carried I will now put a substantive
motion to to the vote and can I have a
show of hands please and keep your hands
raised while the record is taken all
those in
favor thank
you all those
against any
extensions thank
you the substantive motion is carried
thank
you motion 90 the next motion is cross
party motion on baby box and I
understand that an alteration has been
proposed and accepted does the council
consent to the motion has altered thank
you Council renis move the motion please
thank you mayor councilors will note
this motion is being moved with an
alteration because no one said that
cross party working was easy the baby
box is a care package given to people
expecting a new baby it's packed full
with all the essentials that new parents
need clothes blankets toiletries nappies
you name it the Box itself doubl as a
small bed and as one mom said to me
recently the baby box comes with
everything important for an important
person and I think that's very well put
what the baby box is not is a new idea
Finland was the pioneer of this approach
where the baby box has been in place
since the late 1930s closer to home the
Scottish government have developed their
own version in each of these places the
goal has been the same to level the
playing field for children and families
and to make the earliest possible
intervention so that children have the
best start in life nearly a century
since adopting the baby box Finland has
some of the lowest poverty rates
anywhere in the world one in every 20
children in the northwest of England the
figure is one in three one in three
children in our city region go to school
hungry one in three parents at the
school gate struggling to feed or clothe
their child the cost of living crisis
means that child poverty is getting
worse not better and chillingly in some
parts of Greater Manchester rates of
sudden infant death are on the rise so
in child poverty we have a very specific
problem to solve this motion though is
no Silver Bullet and in fact the liberal
Democrats would like to see the motion
go even further in Finland and in
Scotland the the baby box is universal
everybody gets one this motion calls for
a proportional Universal delivery and we
need to be cautious that we do not
inadvertently create stigma around such
a means tested service but Madame mayor
recognizing the acute public sector
Financial pressures we Face the liberal
Democrats have accepted this compromise
if the baby box is going to be
successful as in Finland it will need
long-term support from whoever is in
power that's why this is across party
motion tonight and I'm proud that we
have a motion on the agenda that's been
shaped by all four parties in this
chamber and I ask colleagues to support
it thank you councelor Andis councelor
Paul you got you've got two minutes
please thank you madam mayor I second
this motion because being a mother of
two kids I feel that setting a positive
tone from the start of your parenting
journey is of a Paramount importance the
baby box which comes with lots of useful
items for the newborn baby will help the
new parents to welcome their baby with
some essential goodies each baby should
get the best start in their life and I
think this baby box will help families
to provide that good start for their
baby and will prove to be an extra
helping hand for the new parents who
need to stretch their budget to care for
their new bundle of joy thank
you thank
you I understand that the group leaders
that the cross party motion is supported
by all political parties therefore I
intend to call on one supporter from
each group please Council expert would
you like to support the motion on behalf
of the labor
party um gifting new parents with the
baby box is a lovely gesture to welcome
our babies into the world the schemes
have been successful but I do feel that
due to our limited resources the scheme
requires further investigation as this
motion
suggests rather than offering items
which may not be wanted are often freely
available it may be more effective to
address the issues related to the lower
incomes from reduced maternity pay not
being able to afford the food which is
so important when breastfeeding and the
heating that a baby needs reusable
Nappers aren't much us if you can't
afford electricity to use a washing
machine so we need to be ensuring that
new mothers receive their full welfare
benefit entitlement including the 500 sh
start maternity grant for first babies
and Healthy Start vouchers I so wish new
mothers with financially recompense for
one of the most important jobs they'll
ever do
in addition I feel we should be offering
more supports to community groups such
as a little green sock project in
Trafford who gift used baby b items to
those in need with the underlying
principle of
sustainability and although the baby box
is aimed to reduce cot death there is no
clear evidence that it does so as there
are no safety standards that apply
directly to the safety of the baby
sleeping in a cardo box but the baby box
has been very warmly received in Finland
and Scotland so I would support
exploring whether it would be feasible
to introduce this alongside what we
already offer in Trafford thank okay
thank you
councelor can I ask the leader of the
green party if they would like to
support the motion
please coun to support um we welcome
this motion to look at opportunities to
support children and their parents and
Guardians at the start of their lives
the momentet reports highlights the that
reducing Health inequalities is a matter
of fairness and social justice one of
the core objectives to address these
inequal quties is to give every child
the best start in life here in Trafford
we do have the excellent projects like
uh little like little little green socks
projects and the local hubs which are
offer spe specific targeted support this
includes a lot of recycled products
which is good for community and the
environment and as part of a circular
economy but could families be slipping
the net the proposed motion resolves to
look at feasibility of a box scheme
however it's really important that the
prime considering is prime consideration
is G into Effectiveness not just
feasibility um a recent report in the
Lan actually highlighted that there have
been no R randomized control control
Trials of the effectiveness of baby box
schemes and I think it'd be really good
to ask ask officers and scrutiny groups
to consider working with the local
universities to carry out effective
studies but this should include looking
at Universal schemes as fin Financial
disadvantage is not the only thing that
impacts on outcomes Trafford has an
opportunity to lead the way with the
trial of a baby baby box scheme and
that's to be welcomed and as such we
will be supporting this
motion thank you
counselor the motion um here the motion
has been moved in second do have members
wishing to speak on this motion
please councelor Thomas please
thank you mayor as a proud father of one
of my daughters who is graduating as a
midwife this year I've spoken to her on
this issue NHS Scotland provide B boes
universally through NHS Scotland and she
said the benefit is immeasurable to
every single child is ensured that I
have a safe warm non-stigmatized place
to sleep with mattress and with 4.2
million PE million children in relative
po poverty in this country I think it's
a really good motion and it reinforces
the um claims of the first trial in 2016
that Scotland acted on Wales are also
acting on it there was a trial in 2020
in in
Wales however I hope that this the
outcome of this will be that he places
his responsibility firmly at the place
of the government not a local or
combined Authority via the NHS as in
Scotland thank you thank you counselor
councilor Patel
please uh thank you um uh I'll be
interested to to follow the the um the
work that looks into to this trial I
think it's important that we look very
carefully at the public health evidence
around it and the cost too I was a
member of the um poverty truth um
commission and it would be useful I
think to tap into that resource that
ongoing resource to to get an insight
there uh I know that the SNP were
challenged by the Finish government when
they claimed that their baby box scheme
reduced sudden infant death syndrome it
certainly doesn't and the Finnish
government recommend only using the baby
box to put babies in as the last result
um I I accept that Universal contact
with all expected Mo mothers is really
really important it's a it's a it's a
very vulnerable time regardless of your
background and so that would be welcomed
what families in Trafford really need
pover who live in poverty is Cash in
their pockets to decide how they spend
it and please let us not forget that
there are plenty of older children and
teenagers who do not have beds who
attend school and sleeping on the floor
or um even in bass so thank
you thank you counselor can I have
councilor W
please thank you Madame mayor um I'd
like to I'd like to add my did you say
any sorry sorry go ahead coun I'd like
to add my my support to this motion I I
think is a a lovely idea I'd like to
Echo councelor any is thought um of a
universal provision I'm not a big fan of
universal provision but there may end up
with a stigma attached to it so
Universal provision would be
considerably better um just something
got picked uh councelor Thomas up on H
Health in greaty Manchester is devolved
to us this is something we could do here
we don't need to go to government I
think there is an opportunity perhaps to
engage with business um for SP
sponsorship for Place placement of
products which is some people may not
like but actually placement of product
will get you products and get free
products so there it just needs
explaining exploring really carefully
but I think it's something we could
deliver here in Greater Manchester very
easily thank you counselor councelor
menis
please thank you mayor I remember being
a new mom and I remember the useful bits
not that meant many things but you got
in your Bounty pack the baby box goes a
lot further uh last month I was in
children's A&E sadly and a mother who
was also waiting in A&E with her baby
said that she was struggling with
treating her baby's nappy Rush we're all
sat there waiting together I said that
metanium that we used that came used to
come in the yellow tube was was worth a
try and was better than pseud when you
have severe nappy rash another mom
agreed and pulled the tube out of her
bag to show the other mother what it
looked
like someone told me when when my eldest
was a baby so I remember remember having
the B the bag also having lolan noin the
women in here will know what it is and
why it's important a sample in it and a
miniature little pseudo creme now the P
pseudo a tiny little pot P sudem was
raved about by everybody at baby groups
and it was the perfect size tiny look
you can't buy in a shop and it and it
was car you could carry about for grazes
and things perfect I still have one my
my youngest is 10 years old um I still
have one I refill it for my my first aid
kit that when we go away um so my yeah
my kids aren't babies it just shows how
important it is actually for everybody
and this is why I I would like a
universal box actually and then it
removes the Stig as well it just shows
how important it is to parents to get
the things that you need to care for
your child at the start um The Bounty
pack only had a few items this is a few
little examples the baby box is much
more than the Bounty pack and I think
that it should be given to all all new
parents thank you thank you counselor
councelor Harding
please thank you mayor
um I I supportive of an idea uh that is
a lovely idea about considering the
needs of babies and young children I
don't want us to neglect the fact that
this is wider than a box for a baby this
is about sustainable support that a
family and a mum needs post pregnancy
and postbirth and it was worrying to see
some of the reports reps that came out
about maternity Services across the
country this is a wider issue around
maternal health and Pediatric Health and
as councilor Patel referenced about the
poverty issues so whilst we're looking
at Universal Services it has to be about
access that a parent has to look at
mental health and well-being how to feed
a child how to care for a child and look
at the wider family implications so yes
I'm supportive of something such as this
but I don't want us to just be covered
in Rose tles and fluffiness and thinking
this is all wonderful when we actually
know that the world isn't wonderful for
an awful lot of people an awful lot of
new moms there is so much more that we
need to be doing rather than just
thinking of a universal baby box but of
course I support the motion thank you
thank you counselor Council renis as the
original propos of this motion you have
got two minutes please I think I'll be
brief Madame May thank you and thank you
to colleagues across across the whole
chamber just for the um really robust
and positive debate that we've just had
um I'll reference some of the points
that were made councelor Paul and
councelor Min have spoken from personal
experience and I think that's really
important to be hearing councilor Axford
talks about the further investigation
that the motion outlines and and the
need for that I think the need for that
is very clear um councel Axford and
councelor Lester in fact referenced
little green sock which is which is in
the motion and it's right that we
Champion them and and other Charities
councilor Lester made a point which I
think is sums this up for me this motion
cord has the opportunity to lead the way
um I just want to come on to some of the
points made by councelor Patel because
we have to look at the cost and we're
under no Illusions it's going to be a
challenge but it's worth it's worth
doing I firmly believe it's worth doing
councelor Evans has spoken about
engagement with businesses and I think
that's a very very important part of of
achieving delivery and councelor Harden
has just um spoken really passionately
about how maternity care is in crisis my
partner as a midwife councelor Thomas
and would agree with the sents that your
daughter has expressed as well and I'd
say to council Harding I see that crisis
in maternity care written on my partner
space every single day and it's a big
big contributing factor into why we've
brought this motion to the chamber thank
you thank you
counselor I will now put a motion to the
vote and can I have a show of hands
please and keep your hands raised while
the record has been taken all those in
favor all those
against any
abstains
no thank you the motion is carried thank
you motion 9f councelor chakrabati
please can you move the motion
concerning the alter and minor injury
unit and also you'll have three minutes
now because we are doing well good time
thank you thank you Madame
mayor the old minor unit uh injuries
unit when it was open catered to Cuts
Burns injuries uh sprains which didn't
need any theater so it was meant for
cold cases and it did serve a purpose
and there there is data proving that it
also served areas of broad Heath
altering room and Bowden hail and
surrounding
area since it was closed on the 1 of
April due to the co p pic it was briefly
opened or uh reopened on the 24th of
June 21 and again it was closed on 28th
of July 2021 citing that there was
enough of staff there was not enough
emergency practitioners so given the
remit of the minor
injuries recruitment over the past two
years has been sorted that we are told
and in the health scrutiny committee
meeting in October 2022 it was uh
confirmed that there is plans and
Provisions for it to be reopened albe it
that it was it may be in a reduced
fashion or for a part-time um reopening
so that was finally uh confirmed that it
will be reopened in November
2022 um and then the health scrutiny
committee received receiv a report uh in
January 23 and again further in
September
2023 about Urgent Care provisions and
Urgent Care reviews because Health
Services have evolved and there are
Urgent Care Provisions in rest of the
burough for example in traffic General
Hospital in withen Shore hospital or
neighboring stockboard or in Salford so
mirroring that if this is reopened which
is a long-felt aspiration and also a
need of the local local population in
the current minor injuries shape or in
the Urgent Care provision is something
which we would propose from the
conservative group thank
you thank you
councelor councelor Holden to second
councel hold a second the motion please
and you have three minutes
also thank you madam mayor I don't think
I can say very much more that was
already been by colle it seems to me
that having had the honor of opening
that particular Hospital along with the
Duke of bler who got a much better press
than I did for
be it's a criminal waste to have that
facility
closed I've used it my wife was used it
I dread to think what the outcome would
have been if
with it accepted
overloading or to traic General if find
a SL
was this facility is beautifully
positioned beautifully equipped and I
can only
think that somewhere in the system
someone is looking at the two other
facilities that we have and
enjoying the fact crowed that are
overused and that's an impossible
thought but it's the only explanation
that I have why this unit in the heart
of our community is left
unused thank
you thank you
counselor I received notice of two
amendments to this motion invitees
Council Lori to move the First Amendment
and you have three minutes
thank you mayor I'm moving this
amendment because quite frankly I was
disappointed with the original motion
when I saw it last week in fact I was
incensed in all honesty the glaring a
mission of the need to await the Urgent
Care review most ome especially as the
chair of Health scrutiny is part of the
group that submitted this motion maybe
he was uh drowned out by unn
knowledgeable populism run a mo maybe if
the second conservative member and the
person that's moved this motion had
attended Health scrutiny this year he'd
be better informed about what the
council and The Wider GM NHS is doing in
terms of urgent
care the rewriting of history or the
complete tunnel vision of the fact that
their part has been running our NHS for
the past 13 years is especially ging and
I know the leader will probably get up
and say but budgets are devolved to GM
well in 2017 when we were offered 6.2
billion we were told it was too low we
needed 10 billion to fund Health and
Social care in Greater Manchester it is
still too low and that budget need is
still growing across
GM that is the duty of government not of
the mayor he can't fund it himself he
gets money from
government staff shortages real terms
cut Health and Social care budgets no
new contracts for dentists and general
practitioners waiting lists with over 7
million people ambulance waiting time is
on the rise I could go on and on and on
the NH
is not just not just on its knees it is
drowning in the discharged sewage of
this government in this climate we have
the cynical populist shamefully
political motion I could not let it sit
as it was I believe that urgent care and
treatment in local centers is a benefit
to any community and in my role on
health scrutiny I'll be arguing for such
a center at ultr Grim hospital however
the conservative motion is badly timed
unresearched and an insult to anyone who
has half a brain and should be seen for
the populist slogan it has been designed
to create I end simply by saying saying
this the NHS is in My DNA it raised me
it housed me and it fed me and this year
has quite literally saved my life I
don't need my motive questions when I
talk about healthc care but as ever the
conservative party in in particular
traffic conservatives it would seem most
definitely do need theirs questions do
your research in future and listen to
listen to some experts in future thank
you thank you councelor
councilor broy will second the amendment
and Council broy you have three three
minutes as
well I don't need three minutes but our
libdem amendment has been put together
with a clear understanding of the
pressures that are local NHS is facing
we need to understand and recognize that
minor injuries units are being phased
out nationally and replaced with urgent
treatment centers the evidence is that
urgent treatment C centers provide more
effective efficient and Safe Care the
model we are proposing for altering them
is because we believe that residents in
the south of the bough in alham timley
Broad Heath Bowden and hail should have
urgent care close to home and this model
can only help residents elsewhere in
traffic by freeing up capacity in our
local care
system from the inside as NHS workers we
know the debilitating Staffing pressures
that our NHS faces so as liberal
Democrats we support our health scrutiny
work and this work is reviewing urgent
care and we wish our proposal to be
considered as part of that review so
it's not just A&E departments under
severe pressure but also GP out of our
services in Trafford and we're concerned
that residents in Trafford with mining
injuries are making longer Journeys to
a& in withen Shore particularly in South
Trafford and this is placing extra
pressure on those emergency services
that are already in place so I hope that
members of Trafford Council will support
ourm amendments that outlines why
altering and minor injuries units should
reopen as an urgent treatment center
thank you thank you councelor the first
amendment has been moved in seconded can
I invite speakers in respect of the
First Amendment only and you have aboute
two
minutes thank you Council
later uh thank you mayor um
unfortunately this evening we won't be
supporting the amendment because it is
actually pre pre it's pre can't even
speak again can it's it's actually it's
an assumption that um of what's going to
happen through the Urgent Care um review
and I think that people need to
understand the Urgent Care is review is
not around urgent care center it's
around urgent care across Trafford so
that's Pharmacy provision ision Dental
provision doctor provision Urgent Care
provision and A&E provision so because
the review has not concluded it's
disrespectful to Residents who've been
involved in that process it's
disrespectful to officers who are still
working in that process so we won't be
able to support that thank
you thank you counselor councelor Evans
please thank you Madame mayor um it's a
bit Rich from the lib Dems Council of
poor is suggesting this is for headlines
of all all the people who bring motions
to this this chamber Catalyst for this
motion was ex counil well former
counselor Myers's wife who had several
appalling A&E visits with minor injuries
that could have been dealt with locally
that was our Catalyst and it's nothing
about headlines um the lib Dem Amendment
surprisingly is focused on National NHS
issues we've got two exal candidates in
Council of the pory and councelor broy
in this chamber they know this is
devolved again similar to the baby box
this is something we can do here in
Greater Manchester and something we
should be doing here in Greater
Manchester um the facility is available
we've heard staff of being recruited um
this is the people of altringham that
are suffering and they need their unit
open thank you counselor councelor weton
please thank you Madame mayor um I want
to highlight the uh unanimity shown
previously within this Council Madame
may this motion mentions the fact that
work was done by this council's health
scrutiny committee indeed during my time
chairing that committee we worked very
hard and with unanimity to try to
persuade that the minor injuries unit be
reopened this is not political it's but
a reflection of public move and there
was certainly a strong reflection of of
that from the the committee at um one
particular committee meeting which was
attended by the NHS Representatives
virtually every Committee Member spoke
and spoke urging this uh Speedy
reopening of the minor injuries
unit various indications of reopening
came from NHS Representatives but now
more than a year on the unit remains
closed and I have no idea idea where the
machinations are currently up to with it
but I do know that locally there is
still strong desire to see it reopened
on a proper footing it couldn't be more
clear than than
that that the NHS has a three- tier
model for A&E type care does not mean
that it is delivering suitably for The
Wider alterum area as it stands now one
look at a map and the public
transport uh provision readily displays
that the greater alterum area is an
outlier in need of some of its own
provision such local provision will ease
some of the pressures on other hard
pressed units um where everyone coming
through their doors still needs
registering and assessing before
treatment
commences in effect the minor injuries
unit in altringham provides a structured
triage for a wider area
for the want of that minor injuries unit
the NHS is increasing pressure on its
own other units thank you Madame
May thank you madam mayor so uh in
conclusion we would say like to say that
uh this is a felt need of the local
population of alham and the surrounding
areas the minor injures unit once
reopened will help uh the local serve
the local population and stop people
rocking up into a and with andore or go
up further up to saled roil or MRI
unnecessarily and save them uh cater to
the pro provision of services locally
also it Al increases the pressure on GP
out of our services unnecessarily we've
just heard um that from one of our
colleagues that somebody has presented
with nappy rush to any which is not the
place to be necessarily um and and and
also um this is something which the
provisions are there the infrastructure
is there it's just the timing and we we
would like to know the timeline please
thank you thank you so much councelor I
will now put the First Amendment to the
vote and can I have a show hands please
and keep your hands raised while a
record has been taken and all those in
favor
all those
against any exstension
the first amendment is lost thank
you Amendment two I now invite councelor
cogins to move the second Amendment and
you have uh three minutes councelor
cogins thank you um this has been a
cause of much concern to us as altering
em and halil counselors for a long time
now and it's something that our our
residents are very concerned about and
we do agree with the motion but we feel
that the resolutions asking only for
contact with greater Manchester uh
officials gives the misleading
impression that difficult decisions
taken in GM are taken in a vacuum
unaffected by the cuts of our shambolic
uncaring and incompetent conservative
government um I've been trying to make
sense across the night of the
conservatives new taxonomy of local
versus National issues um as I
understand it NHS problems are 100%
local and we should solve them here the
climate crisis is 100% not local to the
extent that we shouldn't talk about it
here um Banning disposable Vapes they've
voted for so that must be now local and
road safety have put in the third col
volume of down the back of the sofa now
I haven't fully caught up with the
Autumn statement so I don't know if
that's a completely accurate overview
but um our minor injuries unit relies on
nurses and highly trained experienced
nurses at that and after 13 years of cut
to funding our our valued nurses um are
are burnt out and exhausted and I I
think councilor por has has spoken uh
far more eloquently than I can on this
tonight H but we need to train more
nurses and we need to crucially support
them to stay in our NHS for long but
also fulfilling careers H so we're
proposing an amendment that we write to
the Secretary of State to do just this
and we are not prejudging the um report
that we're waiting for an Urgent Care
although we do agree with the libd mo
Move Motion Amendment H that we would
like to see an urgent care center um so
we would ask the council to approve this
amendment instead thank
you thank you
councelor uh councelor Jerome you have
um you're the second to to uh to amend
the amend thank you I have a great deal
to say just to really support the words
that Council cogin has made really we've
seen the um the crisis in the NHS play
out in front of all of us in terms of
the the massive waiting lists the fight
for fair pay ambulance waiting times but
I think the the malaise that this
government has created goes much much
further in the NHS and that is to do
with a shortage of training it is to do
with low pay it's to do with stretched
resources across the board but it's also
to to do with the morale the morale is
rock bottom and and that's the
responsibility of this government so I
think council gogin is correct in in
producing this amendment that takes it
to the Secretary of State as well thanks
chair thank you counselor the second
amendment has been moved and seconded
and I invite speakers in respect of the
amendment to combine speeches on the
Second Amendment and the motion each
member wanting to speak will have only
one opportunity to address the chamber
after these speeches I will move
directly to a vote on the amendment and
then without further debate a vote on
the substan of
motion can I have speakers please thank
you
counselor hearty
please thank you mayor I've been a
member of the um Health scrutiny
committee I think since I was elected in
2019 and the altering and minor inuries
unit has been a recurring item on the
agenda and we've asked searching
questions of Manchester Foundation trust
to ensure there is a secure future for
altringham Hospital members will know
that there's currently review on the way
of urgent care services in Trafford
speaking to the chair of Health watch
Trafford she was happy about the extent
of their involvement and that the voice
of residents was being represented in
that review at this motion as councilor
pory has referenced this is an attempt
by Trafford conservatives to preempt the
outcome of that review it's based not on
evidence or facts but on delusional
suggestions they've made like that the
service is being cut because everyone in
South Trafford has Private health
insurance like so much that we hear from
today's conservative party this is
populist bunker the future of altering
and miners injuries unit and altering
the hospital should be decided on once
we have the outcome of the review and
informed recommendations that we can
consider with local residents I'll
continue to scre ize any recommendations
on behalf of residents and I know me
other members of Health scrutiny
committee will do the same we need to
arrive at a solution for altringham
hospital that is sustainable that is
properly funded properly staffed and
meets the needs of residents in 2023 and
Beyond this motion uh offers none of
that and so I'll be voting against this
motion thank
you thank you and thank you to the green
party for their Amendment and I'll be
speaking directly to that because I've
already spoken enough um we talk about
staff oh there's enough staff the Tori
say oh they've employed enough staff
well actually you haven't because that
20,000 figure you spoke about in 2019
you said you reached it because during
covid you had retired nurses coming back
into the service into that 20,000 they
have now retired again they shouldn't be
included in that 20,000 you've got staff
nurses that are newly qualified that
burnt out by covid that have now left
they're living in Australia and Canada
you've got an education budget that
trains specialist emergency nurses and
advanced nurse practitioners in
emergency care that is sted through
covid that's why we don't have enough
specialist nurses to reopen a minor
injuries unit or an urgent care center
we don't have the specialist nurses
because this government is choking off
funding to education and development and
you're driving away people with low
pay I'm sick and tired of the rhetoric
coming out of this government in terms
of the NHS you are bad for our health
end
of thank you mayor as you'll all be
aware the altering and minor injuries
unit is currently being reviewed as part
of the Urgent Care provision across
traffic
reports have regularly gone to health
scrutiny and that committee is fully
briefed and uh Council abort is the
chair of that committee and under the
people on that committee understand why
the service has been stepped down
altering minor injuries uh during covid
and reasons today which is Staffing
shortages and I don't know where those
other staff have come from either
everyone is aware that Health Service
staff have been depleted have depleted
over recent years for one reason or
another austerity brexit Co and the
staff um the staffing issues um that are
referred to in the motion they haven't
been
resolved Trafford residents have been
accessing Urgent Care from withen Shore
Hospital which is 3.4 miles away from uh
altering and minor injuries unit and
Trafford general which is 7.1 miles away
from altering of VOR injures unit the
two days that was referred to in the
substantive motion uh was residents told
have told us during the consultation
that that wasn't sustainable because
they didn't know if it was a CH they
were supposed to turn up or it was a
Wednesday so it wasn't safe to actually
continue to work with a two-day week um
and the information that we have got
from GPS I just want to refer to that
around out of our's provision there has
been no extra pressure that has been
reported from GPS During the period of
suspension and the system has reported
that our out of hours activity has
actually seen um a downward trajectory
um month on Mon since 2019 so on on that
basis I won't be supporting the motion
thank councelor councelor Men
Please y right councelor Evans
please thank you Madame mayor um I
wasn't i' sort of Le left this to the
rest of uh our team but um councilor
Goggins if this isn't local I don't know
what is this is in your ward you are the
elected representative for this Ward and
you're saying it's a national issue it
couldn't be more local if you tried
we've heard from councelor Harley 2019
he was on the committee there been
calling it for to be opened it wouldn't
be included in the review if they'd have
done if mft who were responsible for it
had opened it we will actually support
your Amendment we don't agree with the
Preamble but the actual content includes
writing to the three people mayor denn
uh I think it's Richard Lee can't
remember the other one but it's all
there they are the people responsible it
couldn't be more local yet the local
counselors saying it's a national issue
it's unbelievable thank you thank you
counselor
do you have any of our speakers thank
you uh coun chakar you have two minutes
to reply should you wish to do
so um thank you Madame mayor uh I'd like
to see the evidence where GPS have told
you that out of hours pressure has been
reduced and I like to also see the
evidence where um nurses can be
emergency nurse practitioners can be
recruited to MRI Hospital the um tamide
Hospital stock hospital and not to minor
injuries unit in
alham it is Beggar's belief that people
would go to A and B and not come to C
for a similar pay structure and and just
to sort of perpetuating a myth that
people are not coming here because
service Provisions are well stretched or
whatever is thus not correct thank
you thank you counselor I'll now put the
Second Amendment to the vote and can I
have a show of hands please and keep
your hands raised while a record is
taken please all those in
favor all those
against thank you any
extensions sorry that amendment is lost
thank you since we've already have a
substantial discussion I propose without
further debate to move the vote to a
substantive motion
please I will now put a substantive
motion to the vote and can I have a show
of hands please and keep your hands
raised while the record is taken all
those in favor sorry sorry councelor
sorry just before we move on we didn't
hear from the labor group at all about
their response to my Amendment um are we
was Did anyone say why the labor group
was not voting for the amendment or did
I because
so the labor group don't want more
funding for nurses that I just didn't
hear that I didn't hear that
discussed
okay thank you right can I now put the
substan of motion to the vote and all
those in favor
please all those
against
any
extensions it's
lost that motion is
lost motion 9g councelor exle please can
you move with the next motion proposing
free and free after tree parking thank
you thank you chair um hopefully I can
bring some Christmas cheer into the room
a little bit dry today uh okay so I'd
like to propose uh for the fre after
three parking scheme for the whole of
the burough um a number of councils have
implemented a variety of free parking
policies and have seen boost to footfall
in their Town centers uh namely
Shrewsbury South End and locally
Rochdale there are other councils who
have implemented a variety of free
parking policies and anecdotally
businesses have relayed that they have
seen a boost to their
business we've seen evidence of this in
chiam North sside the high Highland
Council in Scotland thurk Deni County
Council haret and Brighton and H there
is strong support to small businesses
which suggest that free parking is
something they care about and believe
would result in increased trade for them
Federation of small businesses have
asked members what would make a
difference to your High Street 70% of
those members uh voted in favor of free
parking this has also been supported by
the in previous Communications uh this
evening in the previous motion which has
also um mentioned the increase in
business rate rues as well uh members of
the public when surveyed often states
that free parking is what would make the
biggest difference to them when going to
their High streets a survey done by a
company called xln finds that nine in 10
Brits say they would visit High streets
more if free parking was offered a
survey done by flex. co.uk sites that
87% of people say they would visit
smaller local retailers if paying for
parking was not an issue there are a
number of number of local councils where
parking fees have increased and this has
negatively affected foot footfall and
this would include two pounds for just
spending five minutes in a parking Bay
actually that's D Council in Salisbury a
town in Wales called cardigan had
vandalism issues where their parking
meters were damaged which resulted in
free parking for cardigan this resulted
in an increase in business
football Keith D Keith Davies a fmer
chairman of Cardigan Traders states that
business was better than it had been for
years he was a local owner of a butcher
shop takings rose with free parking up
to 50% for the town's small
shops the best model for free parking is
the three after free the three after
free after 3 Model get my teeth in um
free parking for limited periods periods
is better as it allows visitors to come
in do the shopping get something to
drink or eat and then leave while we
know some councils this is um in the
business desk.com while we know some
councils already operate different forms
of parking con concessions the FSB
believe the first three for fre is the
best the format PR prevents all day
parking but allows plenty of time for
Shoppers to go about their business
without having a rush um I do Express a
further concern that the minimum time at
car Parks run by traffic council is two
hours costing two pound with 250 when
using the app I find that this really
does discourage visitors uh going in to
make short visits to pick up a lunch or
a sandwich or go to the local shop for
something quickly for 153 minutes and I
think 2 pound is certainly way too much
to pay in the long term and not just
Christmas thank you thank you councelor
councelor Lee is the second in motion
and you've got two
minutes I second the motion I reserve
the rights thank you thank
you the motion's been moved and seconded
do any members wish to speak
please
councilor
Patel thank
you apologies uh contrary to the
assertion uh over free parking there is
indeed a cost to the ask here of the
conservative group there's an obvious
environmental one and a financial impact
to the Council of lost income of £75,000
since 2020 when this initiative was last
implemented traffic Council has bridged
a funding gap of over 60 million pounds
this proposal is financially unsound and
we do not support it we have a track
record of investment and business
support in our town centers we are a
joint venture partner to bruntwood in
alham and stretford a partnership that
has guided millions of pounds of
investment into the public realm and the
provision of modern fit forp purpose
business and re retail space brunwood
provide a proactive retail management
role one that close Works closely with
the business Community to promote
footfall and spend we work closely with
ultran bid and Town Center forums in
erston and S this year for example we
are proud to be part of the team that
secured ultr gum's purple flag award for
safety within the nighttime economy we
are directing a significant shared
Prosperity funding to our town centers
we will soon announce a shop Improvement
Grant which will promote a net zero and
promote Net Zero and disability access
this year we have streamlined the
process around Christmas lights
providing guidance and support to local
groups which removes the cost to them of
VAT on light hire and fitting whilst we
were disappointed not to secure leveling
up funds for S Town Center the work
behind that provides a blueprint for
future funding opportunities we are
currently embarking on a review of
erston town center to test its future
commercial resilience at a GM level we
work with the Growth Company to offer
specialist business advice and
networking opportunities across the
burrow this Administration does
recognize the challenges currently
facing businesses it's good to hear news
today that small business relief rate
has been extended what would provide a
better off to businesses in Trafford
this Christmas would be the permanent
move away from the tor's chaotic
mismanagement of this economy a
reduction in V interest rates in
inflation finally to our residents and
members here if you are in a position to
afford Christmas presents this year why
not support local Hospitality give the
gift of going out in Trafford a voucher
for a meal Pub or theater our our local
businesses would appreciate our support
thank you thank you counselor councelor
lorei did you want to speak
thank you may I didn't realize I was
getting called first there um we welcome
this motion but as my colleague said
earlier free parking shouldn't be just
for Christmas um especially in our
smaller Village areas I've actually been
out in my ward talking to business
they're struggling because of as
councilor Patel has just stated the uh
mismanagement of our economy their Lim
limping through at the moment and it's
going to be another hard Christmas along
with everyone else in the country we're
struggling because of this conservative
government um this would have been a way
to alleviate some of that pressure allow
people to come in for three hours for a
few hours after 3:00 for free to give a
little bit more boost to our local
businesses especially in our smaller
Village areas thank you thank you counc
Thomas
please thank you may in in line with
what council pel said what service
should we cut from residents that in D
need to fund this 75,000 loss of income
perhaps the party opposite could get in
touch with jemy hunt and asking to
refund the 288 billion million pounds
we've lost since 2010 because that that
might be able to help us to fix the
roads to alter care uh services and
essentially stop social media videos uh
of counselors in the rain and then per
perhaps then we can offer free car
parking spaces at Christmas I'll be
opposing the
motion thank you counselor councelor
Jerome thanks chair um this motion will
cost the council in the region of
75,000 I I know this is a a snip in the
ocean to councilor Evans but this is a
sizable sum for a council battling the
impact of Tory austerity we also have a
climate mercy and a clean air crisis but
the Tes still cling on to the idea that
free parking is the way forward for our
local economy the government's own High
Street task force say we should reduce
the number of cars entering Town centers
and that we should be investing in
public transport promoting walking and
cycling and creating people friendly
spaces in our town centers this these
are the kind of measures that will help
Revitalize Our Town centers and we know
that people that don't drive stay longer
and they SP spend
more this motion does does say that it
wants to save carbon but as a different
idea I would encourage this Council to
promote emissions based charging in its
car Parks it would Target the most
polluting Vehicles create incentives for
Change and increase transport budget
revenue and we can also do this now so
we won't be supporting this motion but
hopefully the the labor executive will
listen to our ideas thank you thank you
councelor councilor
eners thank you may I was originally
just going to briefly speak to shout out
small business Saturday on the 2nd of
December and I'm sure we'll all be out
shopping local and supporting our local
businesses but I have to say to
councelor Thomas and others who've
spoken about what would you cut charging
people for Village Center parking is a
total false economy it's just it it
would bring in something like 8,000 a
year in simply in fact that represents
something like
.5% of the council's total budget what
good is a few thousand pounds coming in
that way when people start to shop
elsewhere and business rates drops drop
and we see a lot of income the other
way thank you
councelor uh councelor head please just
one second uh may just I can't help what
comment earlier perhaps councelor Evans
could perhaps dig behind his set to find
some Park and Fe to shop local this
Christmas Council rans please
thank you I wasn't wasn't going to speak
Madam may but
um thanks for the personal slight
counselor Jerome you really do cheap in
yourself it's not appropriate at all
this again is a local issue and and I
suppose really I'm focusing on Ultram
because that's my side of the b um we've
had virtually no parking in Ultram for
probably two maybe three years Regent
rad car park is is not open is unlikely
to be open this side of Christmas
specifically the businesses on Greenwood
Street are suffering terribly I hear
from them regularly it is virtually
impossible and what we forget about
altringham altringham isn't like Temple
Ultram isn't like hail it is a
destination town probably more like
Chester and you actually if you can't
park or it's you feel a bit AG grieved
at it you know what you go to nsford you
go to wils slow you go because you might
as well so we need to make altering him
attractive and I have to say there's a
lot of stuff in what councelor Patel
said that is is to her credit with
respect to do working with with the
businesses but actually on this one it
is a small ask of the council and
actually specifically in altringham
those businesses are suffering and as a
council we've got a lot of skin in the
game and if that town center is more
successful we as a council will be more
successful thank
you councilor Welton please clearly
councilor Evans doesn't know wum very
well we have we have SSB 2 hours free
parking we have Tesco 2 hours free
parking we have Oakfield road we we have
um the one by the uh um Total Fitness
we've got the one under the under the
cinema we've even got some parking by um
uh by the the hotel the horrible ugly
one um oh my goodness the uh We've we
we've got if you want really cheap
parking this £20 in Bow moral bow moral
Road just off Moss Lane I mean goodness
sake altering and bid now I go and meet
altering and bid because I'm a really
active counselor dealing with business
Sound Town Center business all the time
I go to meet with alterum bid all the
time if you they have a board in there
that has a list as long as your
arm of new businesses that are opening
in alrum you can barely get a premises
in alrum at the moment it's incredible
yeah if one business closes there's
about five that want to take that unit
and if there's a if you might see a unit
that's not open yet but there's sure as
hell an agreement or it's just about to
be done up and something's going to do
going going to happen actually actually
people seem to have forgotten about the
Regent Road car park a lot of people
have forgotten there was even a car park
there in the in in the first place and
how you know if Regent road is so bad
considering it's just had 2.3 million
pounds of money spent on it and is
absolutely beautiful and everybody on
that I speak to on the doorstep seems to
be Absolut abolutely delighted um with
it if it's so bad why has the new
Jewelers just opened up on it why is a
bakery just opened up on it um you know
it's incred and why is the bid holding
its Christmas lights celebration on
Region Road because we should be
celebrating that development that
actually encourages people to walk and
to cycle into the Town Center which
exactly what they should be doing in the
first place and counil Excell I IDE that
we should be bringing back 30 minutes
free parking is ridiculous because that
just means people nip grab a kind pint
of milk and go home yeah they don't stay
for the for for for the you know for the
eating and the dining and all the things
you counselor sorry thank
you Lena please can thank you may how
how do you follow that
um there's much I agree with with with
councelor Welton and um I I was just
reflecting then I'm you know around long
enough to remember when we were debating
about what the start of austerity
between removing um £500,000 from our
children's centers and handing it back
to subsidies to car Parks I only wish
now that we'd supported the children's
centers because a lot of the demand
pressures that we have right now that we
face as a council as councils do across
the country we wouldn't have them as
much um just it's focused still on alrum
slightly thanks to councilor Evans I
just want to remind people a lot of what
councelor Patel was saying about the
millions of pounds of public realm
investment this Council has been putting
in in recent years the joint venture
that we have with bruntwood which is
transforming where rackams used to be
some real place-based shaping going on
our close work with ulring and bid the
fact that we as we both know the um the
purple flag award and all the other
things they do to bring businesses
together Ultram is thriving we are so
pleased to see that as a council we are
very proud of ringham as a thriving Town
B town center and we are very proud of
the support that we've given as Trafford
Council and this labor Administration
but I don't want to neglect the other
things that we're doing we are putting
millions of pounds of regeneration into
stretford to support our town center
there we are developing sail Moore and
hail Place plans to support our town our
village centers there and give that
sense of place and we're looking at what
we can do to further support the good
work that's been happening in Herston
and seil has had a wonderful private Le
regeneration itself with the support of
our Waterside Arts culture offering
there so there is so much there that's
going on despite anything else that the
conservative group have been saying
because we care about regenration we
care about odd time Town centers and we
will continue to deliver and support
those businesses there thank you thank
you thank you
leader I will now put the motion to the
vote and can I have a show up hands
please and keep your hands raised while
we
sorry right go ahead
councelor uh
oh yes sorry con go ahead uh thank you I
think for comments in the chamber uh
just want to say that I think the
premise of the motion has been lost a
little bit um Council won mentions about
the availability of parking this is not
about the availability of parking it's
about the cost of parking for residents
and how reducing and making parking free
can benefit local
businesses um regarding the 775,000 loss
that was U commented on uh I agree with
councilen
comments um why why do we have a minimum
of two pounds just to just to nip into a
place in the car P why can't we have 15
minutes 30 minutes free or 50p or a
pound something if you're working on a
construction site locally if you're
working locally and you just want to go
and get a sandwich from the from the
local bakery it's cost you an extra two
quid a day it's not fair regarding the
environmental uh impact mentioned by
councilor Patel uh free parking is in
operation for a number of supermarkets
and in shopping business parks and
shopping centers like the traffic center
charging for parking in town centers on
or around the High Street deters
Shoppers from coming to the High Street
and redirects them to shopping business
Parks supermarkets and shopping centers
where there is free parking for some
time this will mean longer trips in the
car to places further away from their
home like the Trafford Center chest
ropes and Trafford Park these longer
trips in cars will produce more carbon
emissions than shorter trips in the
towns would create I refer to an article
from the telegraph could free parking
Save Our Town centers
only 40% of our total spend now takes
place on Britain's 5,400 High streets in
similar shopping areas 97% of groceries
are purchased in the country's 8,000
supermarkets which also allocate more
than a third of their Total Space to
other Goods the tally of shops in
Britain has fallen from 750,000 to
250,000 since the 1960s while the number
of Superstores recently grew by 35% in a
decade some 40,000 shops now stand empty
now perhaps if we could encourage people
to go to our local Town centers our
business rate relief wouldn't be as much
needed regards to driving driving is
important because I to be honest with
you if I'm going to cycle to town
centers I don't know how much I'll be
able to carry on my on my
back when I'm wearing my finest chinos
uh I can't really guarantee that the
weather's going to be that great might
might damage them as well so it's a
serious motion please consider consider
it I know you thank you counselor thank
you I will now put the motion to the
vote and can I have show hands please
and keep your hands raised while the
record is taken thank you all those in
favor all those
against any
extensions that motion is is carried
thank you
sorry sorry that motion is lost thank
you I think that's the end of the
meeting and uh thank God
and I take this um of your attention and
extend a general invitation to the
Parlor if anybody would wishes for come
for refreshments and thank you everybody
and I hope you have a a good rest of the
evening thank
you
wow thanks like that thank you